you don't believe in yourself
simple
you've you've been told or you've been
fed a whole bunch of [ __ ]
from somebody or some people in your
life whether it's culture school
parenting family whatever it happens to
be that
you can't do something
there's
at least one pod podcast interview on my
channel with
sean stevenson he died a few years ago i
caught him on a podcast a few months
before uh he had a tragic accident
passed away but a little dude was in a
wheelchair broken all the bones in his
body several times uh was disabled
made millions of dollars
married a pretty girl
was influential people looked up to him
the point that i'm making here is when
you believe in yourself
when you're mind's eye and
psycho cybernetics is a great book by
the way by maxwell maltz you should
check it out it's on my recommended
leading this but
when you believe in yourself and you
understand that your mind's eye like
like the vision for yourself
now becomes the blueprint for your new
life you become that new life you know
you become that new guy
um
boiler room great movie it's probably
one of my favorites there's a big scene
in that where ben affleck walks into the
um
uh meeting room you can go look it up
it's probably on youtube somewhere you
don't have to watch the movie um
throws down the keys to his ferrari
throws them on a table just goes [ __ ]
ferrari 355 spider yeah [ __ ] sort of
thing
and then you know towards the end you
know once he's got everybody's attention
he's basically telling all these sales
reps to act as if
and
you know there's times in life guys
where you have to act as if you're more
than what you are
i'm not saying be deceptive on a
long-term basis
and
do things that are harmful to people
but
at least wake up in the morning
do the work start taking action and
start acting as if you're better than
what you were yesterday
do an extra push-up if you do 10
push-ups do 11.
if you're at the gym and you're there
for 30 minutes spend 45 minutes there uh
if you do 10 minutes on the treadmill
throw an extra minute or two on right
you know like the taking action parts
part of it but start acting as if you're
better than what you actually are right
i know some of this stuff might seem
seem complex
but it should be clear
um we talked about glass ceilings
you can okay you know here's another
good reason why a lot of people are
[ __ ] poor um
i've been in the debt business for a
long time since
1992 or three some of you guys weren't
even born then
started my own business in 2003
and i came to realize
um you know after spending a good ten
thousand hours in the industry
that
the reason why most people have debt and
the reason why they're poor because of
the debt is because they can't do basic
math
and i'm not saying that to disparage
anybody it's a fact of life if you spend
more than you make
you can't do basic math if you make
three thousand four thousand dollars a
month but you spend thirty five hundred
forty five hundred dollars a month
you're spending more than you make
you're not able to even do basic math
and income minus expenses is a very very
simple equation to figure out i don't
know why they don't teach it in school
they teach you all this [ __ ] other
[ __ ] [ __ ]
uh that you never apply to real life but
so many people out there today are
carrying unsecured debt credit card debt
lines of credits overdrafts sundries um
very very high interest rates on
high-risk loans car loans leases and
stuff like that because they're not
doing basic math in their head and
it's a fundamental concept of wealth
creation spend way less than what you
make right
um let's cross that off here's another
one
so
when my
my dad's generation you know i would say
so there's um
i don't know if it's in canada anymore i
think they closed down most of the
operations there was a outfit called um
marks and spencer very popular in the uk
and i remember this story um like today
you'll go to a store if you want to buy
a sweater
and you put your credit card down you
buy it and then they send you the bill
and you're supposed to pay it off in
full when you get the bill
a lot of people don't do that though
they'll just make the minimum monthly
payment sort of thing but they've got
the sweater
so the concept of delayed gratification
is foreign to a lot of people today
because
we live in a society where it's pop this
pill lose 25 pounds in three days rub
this cream under your eye wipe away 15
years of wrinkles sort of thing like
this is what people want they want
instant gratification you know that
instant dopamine
that's why porn does so well for a lot
of guys it's instant dopamine hit they
turn it on they play
they do their thing they're done right
and that instant dopamine hit
it's dangerous
back to the story you know of the old
man with the marks and spencer and the
sweater
back in those days if you wanted that
sweater you'd go work you'd go to the
store you'd put down your couple pence
or you know if you're in canada whatever
you know whatever buck or two sort of
thing and then you know you go back to
your next paycheck and you pay you know
make another installment until you were
paid in full and you take the sweater
home sort of thing they don't do that
anymore and marketers figured out a way
to you know to basically manufacture
money out of thin air and give people
stuff immediately to sort of
like cater to that instant gratification
there's a very interesting book the
author's name is near al and the title
the book is called hooked the subtitle
is something along the lines of how
habit-forming products are created
um the book mostly focuses on digital
stuff like um social media
uh notifications on facebook instagram
twitter tick tock stuff like that um
there's case studies in it about world
of warcraft
and you know things along those lines
and every
piece of technology today including
financial instruments is engineered
to
make sure that you feel
a positive
rush a dopamine rush a hit right that uh
you know that neurotransmitter hit that
makes you feel good right i remember a
buddy of mine you know he would you know
he would tell me that whenever he fell
down he would go shopping and he would
buy new new clothes to feel good
and
that didn't change that he had shitty
game with women and women didn't want to
be with him on a long-term basis that
didn't change the fact that he was fat
in the clothes and even though they were
nice clothes and they look
like nice clothes he didn't look good in
them it didn't change any of those facts
but the dopamine hit when he went to the
store and he walked out you know from
the uh the store with a new bag in his
hand wearing it you know to the office
to whatever event you know we happen to
go to and he and he thought that he
looked better than he did before right
delayed gratification is an important
thing and
it's a lost art um
i've been
training since i was
i don't know 13 or 14 years old my dad
gave me um
a direct response mailer which i think
was charles atlas's
uh program called dynamic tensions you
can go google it you know dynamic
tensions google uh charles charles atlas
um and it was a black and white
sequence of like workouts that you do
push-ups things like you know this if
you wanted to do uh like a chest workout
you push your hands together if you want
to do your biceps you would create
resistance this way sort of thing and i
would do these exercises even at 13
years old i'm close to 50 now i've been
working out for that period of time
and you know people you know i see it
sometimes in the comments of the videos
rich you look good you know you're
putting off aging sort of stuff like you
look better than most 20 year old sort
of stuff yeah because i've put in the
time i've put in the reps the late
gratification right and
i'm i'm doing the best that i can for
myself so i can live in a happy healthy
body and live a great life but
that's that's ingrained in my dna and
most people don't have that they don't
understand you have to put in the time
um
they're either lazy stupid or maybe even
arrogant you know to be honest with you
and that's why you know they're
generally porous because they don't want
to do the work they
don't know how to do the work which
doesn't make any sense to me because the
resources are there you know you can get
the information you can go find it
or they just don't feel like they don't
need to because they're arrogant hey
guys i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you